agradecimientos entre las ruinas en la
ciudad de los cayos supervivientes del
terremoto retoman los ritos semanales
dan las gracias por no haberlo perdido
todo y conservar al menos la vida sabes
fusión este servicio es especial tras el
terremoto normalmente hacemos un
servicio cada domingo incluso por la
noche pero por culpa del terremoto no
nos pudimos encontrar hoy era necesario
dar las gracias a dios nos protegió no
morimos
según las autoridades haitianas cerca de
600.000 personas se vieron afectadas por
el seísmo en la ciudad más impactada
autoridades y vecinos continúan
organizando la ayuda de emergencia a
escala local we are here today en tu
estamos aquí hoy para ayudar a la gente
que necesita comida agua y otras cosas y
desde acá no tenga we que traemos esto
para ellos una de estas bolsas puede
durar una semana
keep the wind mientras a nivel
internacional se refuerza el envío de
suministros al país más pobre de américa
el sábado despegó de argentina un avión
con material y personal médico y
paramédico y este domingo salieron de
brasil 32 bomberos para asistir en la
búsqueda de cadáveres entre los
escombros una semana después de la
catástrofe sobre el terreno no descartan
un milagro hay unas tablas evitan que
las cosas 72 horas es cuando se torna la
mayor posibilidad de sobrevida pero todo
indica que hay una posibilidad mínima
hasta después de una semana entonces
pues conmigo ya sé que estamos
cumpliendo una semana pero no lo
descartamos es ese milagro no porque
justo tiene allí en 2010 después de 79
días saber cómo era gente conmigo el
reto de las autoridades haitianas es que
a diferencia de lo sucedido en 2010 esta
vez no se cronifique la crisis desatada
por la catástrofe natural que se suma a
la crítica situación sanitaria política
y de seguridad preexistente al terremoto